we're inner-city in Flushing Queens
right we are with our friend Inka lamb
who is going to serve as our translator
today what are we doing here in New York
City today we're doing ping duck
that's right season finale I'm so
excited pecking dog is one of the most
epic meals in human history it is a
specially prepared whole real stuff and
it's known for its extremely crispy skin
it's super tender meat and it is
absolutely delicious it was for Chinese
emperors and so today we're gonna live
like kings and queens yeah let's do it
today onwards that we're gonna be trying
three delicious picking dishes at three
drastically different price points to
find out which one is the most worth it
at its price so I actually have not had
much Peking Duck
ever in my life whoa when you go to get
picking duck it's like celebration feast
I like all those things yeah and that's
also why we brought in because you know
you love the duck I do love the duck I
can eat a whole duck by myself kind of
love the duck what really eat all right
let's go see some duck hey how pointing
him into a like that make one terrible
pilot that Tony Zucco yeah to getting
him into a liner just sees a woman Erica
Virginia human jaw Peking duck sandwich
again her attitude was little feet are
huge other 22 visiting my donated ease
as I saw with the chance with charges
campaign later Superman girl intolerance
to top it all of 18 yards we all sitting
at Yahoo yeah no moratorium this is so
technical gaps in summer because Danny
Trejo Omega yacht regatta Telep seeds
have retreated on space shuttle make a
sauce planted a yard from a single copy
on Johanna and go to Colonel I'll a hole
on attach is so supona about the
quadrature it's yachts and I thought I
out pops a hormone this I saw that Lake
now educate packet color like a patinaed
about the whole policy on tomato farm
piggy and an egg appear in which that's
really hope you'll unlock he punches in
the same it'll be a woman's the godson
appetite it turns over I'll go watching
the tide in a milder popper to see just
obscene I see they also check naloxone
up and say yeah peace and they don't
wait up
so you pace our house ends yeah hey
sonic gets home it's another class yeah
that's really you know show your care
your trip your room so you're about to
see this house
did you eat a lot of thinking doubt when
you were a kid to see which also what to
the boudoir so yeah well Jo kya
how are you know what is it up make it
look it's lovely to find out what drink
do we have here income it's like in
Chinese herbal drink so it was really
good for you is just very Sheree but
it's good
let's see some duck it's a dollar 25 for
this button oh for two bonds we got 250
250 all right let's see what this is all
about look at that house made fun this
is only really one two three four five
ingredients
[Music]
mmm that bun texture like I'm not even
holding I'm funny
it's just duck hovering between my
fingers so this is your first experience
eating taking duck
he's not just roast duck what do you
think I'm struggling not to eat the
whole thing is very very delicious
little bite of the raw honey Anna
matched with the really fatty duck is
they very well figured out an outfit for
him very delicious I love this story
about how he was like I didn't get be
thinking that as a kid yes I'm gonna be
a man the people that is the best
superhero origin story I've ever heard
what's Alan's a great hero named duck
man would be too easy
my only complaint is that it was over
too quick oh yes should I say it was
over - quack okay so we couldn't leave
without getting more snacks and I saw
this guy I was like I gotta get back cuz
I love this so much this is a ride no
it's yo tell my precision I'm good okay
[Music]
hmm Peking Duck
speaking duck fat take it off back there
is a very popular picking done
restaurant in China it's called tricky
Chan jito tranchida and they actually in
2014
opened a museum around picking duck
really hello a museum dedicated to food
what food would you create a museum
around like your top three dumplings
noodles bread yes tomorrow morning when
you meet bright and early at the next
spot it's called decoy very traditional
style but they do have their own twist
very crispy very delicious
all right a guy who's honking this
my name is Ed Schoenfeld I'm the
managing partner creator of decoy
restaurant so where did your interest in
making duck begin my interest began with
my overall interest in food and cooking
and specifically Chinese food and
throughout the late 60s and early 70s it
came the cooking student of a group of
Chinese master chefs
I knew that my partners love taking duck
I've always thought that there was a
need for a Peking duck focused
restaurant that held itself to a really
high standard our head chef here Joanne
My partner is one of the great dim sum
chefs in the world when you get one of
our wrapper it's a world-class pancake
and the first step in making a baking
duck in our kitchen we take the inside
of the duck and we put Bice's scallion
and ginger and star anise and a little
cinnamon some sugar and some salt and
then we put a skewer so that this
flavoring agent stays inside we attack
the end of a bicycle pump and we blow it
up like a balloon it causes the skin and
the fat to separate from the meat of the
duck we take a big wok full of boiling
water and we drag it real quickly
through the boiling water to get the
skin to get tight we marinate the duck
and we paint it with a sarah the syrup
is water that has a little sugar and red
vinegar in it and we hang the duck off
the skin dries so that the skin is very
crispy because the goal of picking duck
is to have very very crispy skin we have
our custom made making duck oven the
Ducks
cook quite quickly they cook in 45
minutes when we butcher a DA starts by
taking big pieces of skin off like this
and the meat we lay it out on the plate
and then we put the pieces of skin on
top we also garnish our dogs with
classical garnishes which is shredded
scallion and little batons of cucumber
traditionally when you serve taking DUP
you use our sauce that is called hoisin
sauce and then we serve sesame paste
sauce and cranberry sauce there are 12
pancakes that come with one dog take our
duck carcass ism' make a really rich
broth from them and when our guests sit
down and get a picking tubs we bring
shot glasses of duck consomme that's how
we serve our duck with those sauces and
those condiments
so the first thing you want to start off
with are these amazing advertisers as
they yes the cutest of the bunch shrimp
and snow pea leaf dumpling without plump
this guy is
little plump Ling mmm now I've had some
of the best dumplings I've had here we
got three colored vegetable dumplings
cats pastrami egg rolls here's the
crispy duck and crab dumplings we're
here for the duck too much of a need or
too much of a decoy all right I could
have left happy after the dumplings but
then I saw this we even have some
special sauces here the duck consomme
yells aha
Wow Inca do you mind teaching us how to
create our own wrap so you grab a piece
of pancake you take however many pieces
you want you put it on my top half of
the pancake like that you grab a little
bit of scallion take this you wrap it in
half and then you wrap it like this oh
yeah if you turn it over that's like
putting a baby in a blanket so then you
get this this tastes a lot like the one
I had a major it's so good okay yeah
yeah okay thank you I'm ready to eat
let's get the skin and meat as suggested
by Ed okay don't get that scallion
inside oh yeah followed by a blanket
swaddle swaddled oh my gosh look come on
compare all right fine
oh that skin is so crispy
I so love that I get a little crafts to
do during my meal I actually go this way
for it I don't know that's right but uh
it's more like a burrito okay I'm really
struggling you want to eat mine
no yes yeah mine no I'll make my own mmm
all the bests like food additives and go
with this tender crunchy succulent
fresh crispy sweet delicious this is a
the rest of it goes in it okay
so add a little break I wanted to bring
you guys to one of my favorite dessert
spots in Chinatown here in New York so
we're here at the little one they do
awesome Japanese desserts but I got us
some shaved ice Oh
I'm far away it looks like a cabbage
it's like combed as well mmm
picking ducks the origins of taking the
duck trace back to the 13th century
although the exact origin is unknown
there are many who believe that it
actually originates from Mongolian
barbecue I wonder when they figured out
how to puff up the skin
oh yeah that is a wild thing to do to a
thing to cook it our last spot now we're
going to a restaurant right down the
street
pod hua Lian so uh we're not gonna get
dug we're gonna get the feast version
how many courses you want to do sure
let's do eight five twelve twelve I'm
the chef tank restaurant owner and the
chef if I was to join you and today I
Colleen presented to the taking down
Testino 1967 my photo pin' to harvest
wine and up to my father passed away I
was running the whole restaurant
business this menu is not like a monster
Chinese restaurant ever to Android but I
only have a hoodie I turn each dish it's
different tastes different sauce today
the Chinese will change your love I'm
not saying change is not good but I
wonder people are educated about 40
years ago 30 years ago was very
traditional Chinese food we just present
a very simple like a kabob people put a
green paper read papers allowances but
know this restaurant kimochi only
chicken only hot pepper in the county so
today we're gonna have the baking duck
guessing picking duck will marry an old
overnight we use a different ingredient
how to make the skin dry you know we we
gotta keep it at wash our make it a
crispy skin
you can tell it was big secret in order
ingredient will you sir rice water who
useless for pace is very starchy because
the rice have stuck in there after
browsing we need a puppy like 12 hours
or 10 hours for the air dry the skin the
tradition will conquer Chinese food Yuri
came car show car so the way I've taught
my chef
don't rush make sure this each dish is
fried taste if you the duck will try to
present a right time in a half hour
we're coming out open an hour later the
duck skin or use a bit cold right away
ricotta
you take the skin without any sugar
without nothing it's like butter
hi everyone welcome to yn we're excited
for the signature dinner which has a big
peaking dog so we're gonna have nine
dishes today nine that's a really good
number in the Chinese culture first
there's just of course the coal noodle
with sesame sauce we're gonna noodle
cheers Cheers
[Music]
spicy peanut butter cold noodles you
know a lot of people will find that
combination strange it is so delicious
when I just stuff my face with his
noodle because it's so good the second
dish would be the shell bow which is
soup dumpling with port I'm just going
to go all in oh yeah also plump and then
we're gonna go with the soup it's a
chicken soup with pork rib and also some
Chinese herbs mmm so this is a very
gentle introduction to the payoff mm-hmm
I like our slow very slowly escalating
is it that time
no for the entree we starting with the
Pekin duck it comes with three sides of
vegetable Asian pear cucumber and also
scallions my mouth blends whatever
saliva producing plans I have in my
mouth absolutely has just opened up the
heavens
sounds like scissors on paper maybe my
next video just be I'll learn how to
carve picking it up you can't even do
the wrap I think you're in the car over
the duck oh look how oh my gosh that's
the duck butter
ah is the duck butter
[Music]
oh my gosh it's so crispy that every
single like its moist like a sponge is
moist yes I feel like swallowed the
juice as I'm chewing the rest of the
meat Wow do pancake times let's do it ah
so let's build some pancakes
pretty good Stephen thank you how you
eat for what you can get here in New
York this is probably the closest you
can get to like the traditional in China
yeah Thank You doc how's the peanut
we're gonna start with one of our
classic dish it was just compiled
chicken hmm that has a very nice bite
this spice is like just there the next
dish is the orange beef so on the menu
it says marvelous onsh beef but in the
Chinese character it just means tanks
chicken because there's no name for it
we have beef nugget mmm and it's not
orange overwhelmingly the next dish we
have is a Mapo tofu very tender tofu
there tofu is like extra soft
I'll get cuz it's low like peppery we
got to have the most delicious meat
before we amped up with the spice yes
and now the meal just gets more and more
exciting and then of course we have to
have vegetables right well we have
Chinese food so we have a fry rush no
dish which is the streaming and then you
have the snow peas just poach in a
chicken broth that we make in-house you
know like as I kid I didn't understand
why people didn't like vegetables
because when you eat vegetables like
this there's no question that it's
delicious I really like how we went from
light to heavy to light taking the
banquet feast mode a smart way to eat a
delicious meat it's just like being able
to see all the foods lay it out and like
really really well-balanced meal they
took a lot of time to prepare each dish
and I really appreciate that New York
City baby I'm talking about called
Andrew which taking judge spot what's
the most worthy you at its price my
worth it winner go
to the Peking duck sandwich stall it's
both special but casual it's just a
great time if it was a dumpling episode
who would do decoys dumpling that was
words crazy I'm gonna have to go with
Hawaiian right here trying to house my
with a winner
eating with friends the duck was so
buttery and so delicious it wasn't manly
I loved it what we're doing with the
winner Alan he is bringing speaking
about to the masses like everybody can
enjoy it Adam who's worth the winner Wow
three-on-one Anka thanks for joining us
today I'm worth it thank you for having
me that's a wrap on the season for worth
it thank you for joining us on season
four it's just been an amazing ride so
from me Adam and Andrew thank you guys
we love you we'll see you next season
all right that's a wrap hello Steven
here thank you so much for supporting us
and watching board if the last four
seasons I have a very special
announcement for you which is that we
have some brand new merch go to shop
BuzzFeed comm click on worth it we have
four brand new t-shirts we have a new
hat
it has a cube adorable worth that logo
on there we helped design the stuff
we're really excited about it and thanks
again
we'll see you season five
[Music]
hey check out our Instagram it's new
it's at BuzzFeed worth it see you guys
there
oh yes